[Música]
bienvenidos a 5 minutos con en medio de
un panorama muy difícil después de 10
años de una sangrienta guerra siria va a
las urnas para elegir a un nuevo
presidente aunque de acuerdo a las
encuestas y a las opiniones hay un
favorito y es el actual mandatario
bashar al-assad quien garantizaría así
la permanencia de su familia en el poder
político de siria al asad se enfrenta a
dos candidatos más en unos comicios que
no cuentan con el apoyo de la comunidad
internacional y tampoco de los
organismos internacionales como las
naciones unidas para analizar este tema
invitamos a ignacio álvarez ossorio
albariño él es profesor titular de
estudios árabes e islámicos en la
universidad complutense de madrid- nos
atiende a esta hora gracias por estar
con nosotros
a esta hora señor álvarez ossorio y
comienzo por preguntarle qué significa
para un país como siria que está en
conflicto que haya un proceso electoral
en donde ya prácticamente hay un claro
ganador
no significa absolutamente nada porque
llevamos más de 50 años de gobierno de
la familia assad y lo único que
aparentemente se quiere dar es una
cierta fachada democrática que concurran
otros candidatos para que la comunidad
internacional piense que se dan
diferentes opciones a la población siria
pero en la práctica todo el mundo sabe
que el único candidato con posibilidad
reale es bashar al-assad y que
probablemente el número de votos que
tengas sea superior como en anteriores
ocasiones al 90 por ciento por lo tanto
se trata de dar una fachada democrática
a un proceso claramente
a democrático usted habla de fachada
democrática le pregunto entonces por las
garantías de este proceso electoral en
términos de instituciones que lo
supervisen el proceso los observadores
garantes
que dice la comunidad internacional
sobre estos comicios
lo que pidió la comunidad internacional
en su día a través de la resolución 22
34 del consejo de seguridad era que
hubiera observadores internacionales
bajo el mandato de naciones unidas que
es algo a lo que se ha negado de manera
sistemática el régimen sirio
precisamente por temor no a que no
puedan constatar la limpieza de estos
comicios y por lo tanto no hay una
mínimas garantías legales al igual que
tampoco hay candidatos realmente que
sean de la oposición a un puesto que los
otros dos candidatos pertenecen incluso
algunos de ellos han tenido cargos no
dentro del gobierno sirio y los dos le
digo pertenecen a alguna oposición que
podríamos considerar domesticada una
oposición real y la oposición real que
está en el exilio no puede presentarse a
estas elecciones señor álvarez ossorio
de continuar al asad en el poder tal y
como lo dicen las encuestas siendo el
representante de una de las minorías
religiosas allí en siria esto indica
entonces que el conflicto interno
continúa se va a prolongar más
se mantienen entonces estas disputas
territoriales porque vale la pena
recordar que las manifestaciones que
llevaron a esta guerra civil pedían
precisamente un cambio en el gobierno
sirio
bueno pedían democracia pedían libertad
es que hoy por hoy no existen
en el caso de siria no con este nuevo
mandato ya serán cuatro los mandatos
presidenciales del presidente bashar al
asad y estará al menos en el poder hasta
el año 2028 lo que equivale a 28 años de
presidencia de bashar al asad aunque la
constitución del año 2012 establece un
máximo de dos mandatos no sería de
extrañar que en los próximos años dicha
constitución se inventara para ampliar
el mandato presidencial de bashar al
asad y que pudiera estar tal y como
estuvo su padre hasta el final de sus
días con esto llevamos casi nada menos
que 51 años de gobierno de los asados
aunque en esta ocasión a diferencia de
las anteriores puedan concurrir otros
candidatos la situación en realidad no
cambia no habida cuenta que estamos
soldados
y estamos ante un precio generalmente
autoritario señora álvarez ossorio
brevemente cuáles son los retos que
tendría entonces al asad si vuelve a
estar en el poder
bueno siendo del primer reto que tiene
es la reconciliación interior con los
diferentes partes de la sociedad siria y
el segundo la normalización de
relaciones con el entorno árabe con que
sea readmitido otra vez siria dentro de
liga árabe y por último el tercer gran
dedo sin duda alguna es la
reconstrucción del país un país
devastado por diez años de guerra en un
90 por ciento de la población viviendo
en una situación de pobreza entonces
estos son los tres retos más importantes
que tiene ante sí el señor ignacio
álvarez ossorio gracias por estar con
nosotros aquí en france 24 ustedes
gracias por la sintonía y continúe con
nuestra programación buen día
[Música]